welcome to this video plain Morton this
is more tinley not a very well known
player yeah this movie emotionally
that's some interesting player from
Australia he pleads playing on the ICC
for a long time from a very young age
and always has had very high ratings and
all on quicktime controls and he
recently made the Grandmaster norm by
winning the big toe tournament in
Australia not sure what it was but if he
scored a grandmaster no okay we got a
sloth with the queen bee three white is
playing the setup group d one coming
trying to get get get a simple but sound
position with a slight edge in the
center not much to write home about but
it's a solid and can be played for for
an advantage if black is not not careful
okay who could do one he takes the sin
ID form he is taking didn't expect that
but okay he can play it
yeah with Bishop b3 coming white some
rationale here is that the bishop on h5
is somewhat off side it is some very
often not not doing much I tried to play
this quickly because I know that he is a
very fast player at at the end so I
don't want to get totally behind on the
clock let's see yeah I think g4 f4 is a
bit birdie should probably control C
five-year g4 a form
what happens after g4g five now I don't
really understand at d7 hangs iam this
was an additional threat
okay show me what you got
yeah he just gives away the piece and we
are Queen d2 we are pointing to I guess
yeah that's just a piece for for nothing
much okay I don't open not sure if I
should take on a for this weekend's the
dark squares quite a bit well can I can
play a three but ok I'll just take this
i mean there is nothing going on really
a three there's still this additional
problem that the night on a g6 is not
playing
yeah Queen the queen to d6 looks quite
good just getting Queens off or
centralizing the Queen in case of Queen
a7 shaker Queen deform check
hmm
I'm wondering if I'm threatening night
is six year maybe it looks like a looks
like a threat okay 96 threatening made
on g7 yeah nothing you just not have a
check or anything don't don't see don't
see anything here black resigns yeah we
just blunder the PCM can happen to all
of us I mean I felt like I'm comfortable
here but nothing nothing totally totally
serious here ya get it's just just
blunders a PM Bishop before um I don't
know night-night c5 maybe or something
it's a fairly standard position for this
line where it's always yeah the
evaluation is always between white has a
minimum pull nibble a sense some players
like to say and and and equal here maybe
night a for can be an idea this is this
type of play yeah well this is just
blundering a piece and after that it's
it's basically gone you can just try to
muddy the water a bit but it's really
really very easy to can't win even yeah
not much to analyze he just blundered of
peace okay thanks for watching